F Maurice Ashley with a special guest
thanks alejandro and we've seen this
lady before she played in the Karras Cup
in st. Louis former women's world
champion Alexander Castillo who I
understand you have a place here in
Paris yeah my husband lives here if we
can say so and I come once in a while so
yeah we do have a place here and there
like to come to Paris whenever I have a
chance you say you haven't been able to
stay here too much this year because of
your busy travel schedule yeah this year
is amazing in terms of tournaments
because I I play team candidates in
Karis Cup it starts with the Cairns cup
then we had the World Team Championship
then I was preparing for the candidates
and how made June I was preparing and
playing and now in July I spent three
weeks in China and now I'm on my way
back to Russia
so yeah constant traveling which is a
good thing that means that there are
many tournaments to play and which is
amazing especially for women's chess but
on the other hand here I miss Paris and
it's a nice it's a nice city to be in to
live and I'm very happy to pass by Paris
exactly at the moment hopefully
Grantchester absolutely I feel the same
about New York City and my travel
schedule not seeing too much of home
your feeling about the gran chest or
here in Paris yet again it's got to be a
special thing because they're not a lot
of big super tournaments here in time
yeah this relates that surprises me even
because the interesting in the Romanian
spectators and this year it's actually
much better than the year before I was
here the last year during the
Grantchester and it wasn't the kind of
it was impossible to feel the atmosphere
of the chess tournament and the emotions
of the players and this year is
different but there are some spectators
maybe not a big big hole that would have
been a bit better but compared to the
last year I think it's an improvement
for the chests lovers who can just come
he's a player's connection well for us
to as compensators being right in center
of town is also fantastic you mentioned
you have this place here but you have
some Russian players as well who are you
rooting for it to win this whole thing
well I mean it's difficult to say to
pick only one player we need you to pick
somebody yeah just to win this
tournament oh you mean what do you
thinks gonna win and who do you have a
special spot in your heart for but
Magnus Carlsen is not playing that gives
some other players a chance dude
but maxime beaugeois graphic silent and
he's from Paris yeah and being in Paris
but of course I always work for the
Russian players and I was happy to see
you know young nippon-ichi win his game
and yeah but in this particular
tournament I think Maxim Maxim should
should do it should win because he
missed slightly in the riga grand prix
right in the end in the armageddon game
he lost and you know it gives more
motivation to him because shock rearm
immediate he feels relaxed he won the
trophy and that's it and for Maxim since
he well he barely he he he almost won
but he still has motivation and he I
think he has good chances in this
particular absolutely very good point
before we let you go what's your next
event we should be looking for you at
we're going to play in the Russian super
file which starts in less than two weeks
in the part of Russia or mucha region
and
then I'm going to participate in the
women's Grand Prix that will start in
September in skolkovo which is next to
Moscow good luck with all that thank you
very much for joining us thank you for
woman's world champion is Andrew
castaigne and we're going to take a
short break and we'll be back with final
round action
[Music]